es el lago más grande de áfrica y uno de
los más grandes del mundo el lago
victoria tiene aproximadamente el mismo
tamaño que irlanda con alrededor de 3000
kilómetros de costas limita con kenia
uganda y tanzania pero desde hace algún
tiempo su futuro se ve amenazado
todas las mañanas los pescadores
kenianos son los primeros testigos de la
degradación del medio ambiente en sus
piraguas el 90% del pescado del país
solía venir de aquí
cada día y menos y menos peces
y
antes uno podía incluso peces nadando el
agua era clara pero ahora no sé si es
por la contaminación que viene de los
ríos pero no se ve nada
al acercarse a la orilla el agua del
lago se vuelve opaca y verdosa según los
pescadores muchas especies no pudieron
resistir esta ola de contaminación de
peces anfibios y también plantas lo
mismo dicen los científicos que
advierten del peligro inminente
la situación es crítica es terrible de
hecho es casi un lago muerto el lago
está contaminado con todo tipo de
desechos especialmente plásticos
cuando los desechos plásticos son
arrojados a los canales de las ciudades
que rodean el lago e incluso más allá
todo acaba en el lago de interlake
en pocas décadas 50 millones de personas
han llegado a vivir a las costas y se
espera que esa cifra se duplique en los
próximos 30 años las ciudades cada vez
más grandes pierden sus aguas residuales
directamente en los ríos que alimentan
el lago al igual que las fábricas y las
explotaciones agrícolas en el día a día
todo el mundo se ha acostumbrado a
utilizar el lago como vertedero
todas las noches la gente arroja su
basura y vierte sus fosas sépticas aquí
en estos canales y luego todo acaba en
el río y derriba a las autoridades
locales les cuesta implementar un
programa a gran escala para salvar el
lago victoria así que son los ciudadanos
de a pie quienes intentan hacer que las
cosas se muevan a menudo son voluntarios
muy jóvenes que se movilizan y recorren
los mercados para intentar alertar a la
población hemos venido a decirles porque
esto es peligroso están listos para
ayudarnos a frenar la contaminación si
estamos listos 100%
y juntos realizan operaciones de
limpieza varias veces al mes estos
activistas saben que no resolverán el
problema por sí solos pero quieren dar
ejemplo y mantener viva la esperanza
lo mejor de mi generación es que nos
comprometemos a resolver los problemas y
cuando le mostramos a la gente que
tienen una voz y que pueden cambiar las
cosas nada puede detenerlos es posible
salvar el lago hemos visto como
alrededor del mundo se regeneran los
ecosistemas cuando se les deja descansar
y se deja de contaminar
hay que actuar con rapidez en pocos años
tres cuartas partes de las especies de
peces del lago podrían extinguirse si no
se hace nada y una catástrofe ecológica
aquí tendría repercusiones directas en
casi toda áfrica oriental